welcome back to las vegas now it is
called stubborn fat
for a reason right because you can diet
and exercise and it still doesn't go
away
our next guest does have a solution for
you though let's welcome in lisa brooks
of be
jazzy wellness hey lisa hi hi
how are you i'm good how are you doing
well ready to talk about the stubborn
fat solution
i understand that that is body
contouring right how does it work
correct well it's a technology that
permanently kills your fat cells
as well as train your fat cells and skin
tightening
okay and what areas do you treat or do
you see being treated
most often we most often it is the
stomach but we can treat any area of the
body we can treat the stomach we can
treat the back
we can treat your inner and outer thighs
your arms
we can treat any area of your body okay
that's good to know
and how how quickly do you see resort
results after a treatment you'll see
results the same day
the same day you'll lose up to two
inches oh wow inside
yes that's nice i see we have some
before and after pics let's talk about
those
it's the pictures of the back yes
that's a client who came in and they had
their back
they had excessive raw fat so we went
and did our body contouring and that was
her result
wow and how many sessions were needed to
get this result
four sessions once a week
for results like that the maximum the op
sorry the operative results you'll get
come over the next several weeks as
you're doing the treatment
okay and what about the arms we have a
picture of a before and after oh wow
that's a dramatic change right there
the arms are very interesting to work on
but we get the same results as we do
with the stomach or any other area of
the body
the results that we get are actually
really good we have a lot of people
coming back we have a lot of people
preferring
yeah and the legs i see we have a before
and after of those as well what are the
most
or what's why do people come in for the
legs usually
summertime is coming short swimsuit
season a lot of people will come in
because they have
you know they've had these thighs that
they've had for a long time and they
want to us
to help them take them down and be ready
for swimsuit season
absolutely getting confident getting all
ready for for that here in vegas
especially it's about to get really hot
so do you have any specials for us we do
right now we have forty percent off of
our body contouring for the first ten
callers
ooh we like that thank you so much lisa
you are so welcome all right you can
find more information
at bjjazzywellness.com and take
advantage of that special deal she just
mentioned
guaranteed to lose two inches same day
to the first 10 callers 40
off series of body contouring so call
today 702
800 800-7406 las vegas now we'll be
right back